[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
previously on model lifestyle
[Music]
I thought it's a good time to ask the
killer to talk to you guys because some
of you asked Daniel how does your wife
feel if you do international modeling
how does it feel being married the
distance and then also jealousy and
those kind of stuff so and in the
beginning I'm gonna be honest I was a
bit jealous because I earned my trust
Nikita
earned her trust so it was a very loving
dog yeah he's very special to us
I'm missing my log when I travel we have
confident confidence in who we are as an
individual person yeah and also in each
other and each other
[Music]
all right we're in the car we're in
Victoria and I have to go to
Johannesburg Airport and right now I'm
going to the how train station Tina's
gonna drop me off like she usually guys
Oh another thing about South Africa is
its fourth prime right and we have the
security areas where we live so we have
to use these security tags press it here
so this big gate opens up
[Music]
most the peoples of Africa live in these
kind of security houses this how many
houses is there in this area what an
Aries face
yeah in our state around 200 these 300
all right so let's say there's about 300
houses and they have these security fans
around them with electric wires and
their security protecting us 24/7 yes
South Africa is dangerous we have over
50 murders every day and a government
that is very very corrupt okay but
anyway enough talk about bad things so I
have a direct booking with Hart
Schaffner marks it's a really cool brand
I've worked with them for a few times
and right now I'm just gonna go to
Shanghai I'm gonna stay there for a week
and I'm gonna back to come back to South
Africa
Nikita my wife is gonna stay here
and she's gotta study and work yeah
that is our of life we made a sacrifice
and you still need to study for two
years they need that this
so as you guys now it's an excellent
photographer and interaction
yeah studying at interactionism alright
here we go
this is South Africa have a look at our
Rose
see that only in Survivor again
tractor in the road
[Music]
there's the hard train tracks and I'll
see the station almost there
sorry to stop here yeah I just bought
you this thank you babe love you bye
[Music]
never
[Music]
gasps well now it is a seven wouldn't
suffer all right I'm gonna be a magician
web by using different match for the
lounge
thanks man thank you
[Music]
all right so almost boarding the first
flight is to Doha and then from de hides
off to Shanghai this is my plane right
here check it out
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
right
all right South 2099 D all right see
this that's my seat for the whole flight
to Doha an infidel hasta Shanghai so far
he's not a lot of people on the plane
[Music]
all right so the first part is done we
have arrived at Doha now I just have to
fly left to Shanghai and then we're
gonna start adorable
[Music]
trait thank you
[Music]
all right it's been a long day and I
have just arrived in Shanghai we're
gonna take a taxi to the hotel
[Music]
it's a lot colder in Shanghai and I
thought it was it's very very very cold
oh my goodness it's cold the queues are
going very fast here it's over there
okay number one thank you
[Music]
you know I mean the taxi on the way to
the hotel check out this cool taxi
I think the drivers here protect
themselves of ikana Shula it's kind of
interesting
I hope I don't know if it is the right
place let me have a look here in a head
we're at the right place so right now
it's five o'clock Tuesday and I started
this flight on Monday morning so Monday
is gone and today's also gone I'm super
tired
[Music]
hey thank you thank you ready do you
have a wife
[Music]
my goodness is a lot of rooms here
[Music]
so-called in this hotel room Wow because
the windows are opened don't know why
they open the windows
[Music]
let's check out this hotel room we got
some space to work a little bit tonight
on some of the videos that I can edit
and I can have some let's see what's in
here
what is this what looks like some tea
okay
got some water here so this is my hotel
room for the night not bad not bad not
bad
[Music]
hello Shanghai Wow
it's not a great day a little bit misty
[Music]
Hey good morning it's Wednesday morning
around seven o'clock I had a really good
night's rest now I'm starving let's go
see what Chinese breakfast they have
[Music]
hey now it's okay thank you
okay is the breakfast this morning get
some coffee
don't know what is this
[Music]
some eggs
they don't have a lot of food options
here but at least they have some eggs
and tomatoes I wanted to show you guys
this whole thing this damper here
it's kind of like a Joe and I have some
meat inside just a vegetable
all right so I had a breakfast I'm full
had a good night's rest of energy now I
got a check out and meet up with the
client
let's go oh come let's go
hello how are you
finally we're here are we on the way to
the job she's gonna check out how are
you good
still cold in Shanghai
[Music]
here we go
we just stopped here for a quick toilet
break I just wanted to show you how to
looks like when you stop here to get
some fuel in China they have these kind
of small stores here where they have
some very interesting food let's check
it out
some corn some sausages some eggs
opens
I have no idea what that is
you know
what is this some more sausages and
stuff
these are quite nice I had these before
what is this no idea
it's time to continue on the road
hello
[Applause]
this is our driver for today
just arrived here in the location
somewhere in the mountains
Oh
so this is our hotel here in the
mountains for two days
it's a bird in a cage here veiled yeah
hey buddy
[Music]
so colder yeah
okay so this is not the hotel which is
gonna eat here
[Music]
all right let's go
[Music]
countryside of China
[Music]
Wow this is it oh okay
I have the rest okay okay okay all right
I have a Wi-Fi here okay let's go check
out my room
Oh Italy okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of cool I have a little TV over
here not too bad let's check out the
bathroom
[Music]
it's nice Wow
not too bad kind of cool it's a heart
[Music]
all right this is home this is home for
two days
[Music]